ich bin zebra
den tierpark fahren
diese angekommen hodenhagen serengeti
park
hätte das sind noch keine echten tieren
die sache jetzt dass die meisten halt
mit seinem doppeldecker bus fahren dann
stellen die ihr auto hier auf solchen
parkplätzen ab sodass das auto halt
nicht zerkratzt werden könnte von tigern
affen und so aber wir fahren mit dem
auto
ich weiß nicht wo ich fahrt auf eigene
gefahr
das stift ich habe
meine händen familie da kommt der bus
und der bus heißt die
[Musik]
sache laufen lieber also giraffen ja
wir sind überall so über krasse tiere
und wir bleiben jetzt schon seit 15
minuten stehen bei gänsen diaz
aussteiger strengstens verboten ja was
wollen wir machen da vorne sind giraffen
wusstest du dass ist männliche giraffen
von weiblichen giraffen riechen um zu
gucken ob die paarungsbereit sind
die luft auf uns zu die luft doch wozu
[Gelächter]
die dunklen flecken auf einer rampe sind
desto älter sind die übrigens ihr lernt
hier noch richtig war von dieser fahrt
da gerade hingesetzt und alle sind
irgendwie aus wie eine mischung aus esel
und pferd und ein akku und dir
diesen wissen langweilig tschuldigung
wissen
und geht ich bin kumpel von kumpane
ich will die yoga empfehlen
doch nicht geärgert
deswegen soll wieder zu
alter schwede
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt auf jeden fall in
zentralafrika achtung lebensgefahr bitte
verlassen sie nicht ihr fahrzeug ich mal
gespannt was sie jetzt für tiere auf uns
warten geht sie zu den zebras kag gleich
auf ihr hässliches auto geht sind wir in
europa sei es jetzt kommen
wahrscheinlich tauben
und allerhöchstens mal ein ort also was
ich auf jeden fall schon mal sagen kann
ist dass es hier die ganze zeit nach
scheiße stinkt aber es kommt auch an dir
liegen ich würde euch am liebsten
anspucken wie geht es denn jetzt die
zebras ich steck gleich ein zebra in
dein arsch okay nicht ob das ding lebt
aber nicht das sehen hier einfach so
steht und lebt und er dies nicht dieses
räder angreift
mit wasser im hintergrund und
anscheinend nicht fassen wir haben jetzt
in westafrika erstmal steht was man auf
die fed
dass man jetzt auch die fenster
geschlossen halten sollten ich verstehe
nicht warum wir von afrika wieder nach
europa jetzt wieder nach afrika wir
haben hier tatsächlich nur diese
neuartigen tiere hier und sonst gar nix
außer seine komische figur hier noch in
nordamerika haben wir jetzt einen bison
und abdi und zwergesel
wann kommt jetzt hier mal ein
dinosaurier wasserfalls sieht aus wie
pisse fühlt man sich ja gleich wie in
nordamerika
cassandra hier auch gilt
als entschuldigung
entschuldigung
tschuldigung
entschuldigen sie bitte
entschuldigung
wie kann dieser krisenbedingten
trainerin als mein zebra t shirt ich
fahre jetzt rein in die tonnen rahmens
kann ich nur von minecraft tatsächlich
so dass meistens die lehrer haben wir
irgendein event verpasst sind die alle
auf einer demo hier die tiere oder so
entschuldigung wissen sie woher die
zebras sind wenn du noch einmal nach
zebras fragst was ich dein fuß okay der
amur leopard ist die seltenste großkatze
dieser erde der ist nur am schlafen die
krassesten tiere die hängen den ganzen
tag nur um und schlafen wissen sie woher
die zebras sind
die wo die zebras sind sag mal ist hier
in den lauf über die leber gelaufen
jetzt sind wir in südamerika und hier
steht wieder das man fenster und türen
geschlossen halten sollte die haben mir
einen flachland papier das macht der
das hier sind jetzt wasserschweine
passiert
wir wollen halt die ganze zeit schon
weiter fahren aber
ich weiß es nicht ja verrückt guck mal
hinter dir ist keiner
sitzt hier wo sie zu den zebras geht
hier steht jetzt sogar so richtig fett
achtung danger aussteigen strengstens
verboten und dann gegen diesen tieren
das sind einfach dran die tiere die auf
dem boden liegen bisher muss hier zu den
zebras geht es mal weil sie aussieht so
einen windows und office selbstlos wird
mit so einem fetten pelzmantel oder so
sehen einfach aus als hätten die make up
drauf hier ist jetzt zum ersten mal so
richtig krass abgesperrt damit 8
mein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
absolutes highlight tschuldigung wissen
wie jetzt hier wo die zebras
hat aber auch heißen er ist hier wieder
ähnelt mit der tiger da oben willst mir
mehr als alles andere vom mond wird
wissen sie wo hier die diese hätten die
wieder in afrika aber jetzt kommt man
irgendwie zu den raubkatzen und man darf
nicht mehr mit blitz fotografieren und
wenn irgendwas ist soll man ganz laut
hupend
man dennoch leise hub noch kein sender
alle sonnen kreist roten asche so fühlt
sich mein arsch auch wenn wir nicht so
eine halbe schon einpacken versucht
seinen kollegen glaube ich irgendwie
nach zecken ab oder so schon interessant
dass wir von solchen idioten abstimmen
die haben der bus hat die farbe von
unserem zebra
aber wenn noch kein einziges c
entschuldigung wissen sie woher die
zebras sind 20 meter weiter fahren
da forderte nasaler sträuße hier vorne
sind schwerer okay sind doch nur steine
an ihre chance lauern ich
meine freunde stellt nicht den kopf in
sand davon in den zebras
ich bin einer von euch quasi perfekt
ohren was denkst wie viel wie zur
nashorn
wenn es hier mal einige absolut keine
ahnung ständig noch vor es wird solche
teile in echt geben in der größe so vier
meter lang und damit diesen augen dauer
ich weiß es nicht es aber so richtig
geklappt oder solche fetten spenden
alter bock ich mache fans doch obwohl
ich weiß dass die skulpturen sind hier
vorne machte
war alter das ist eine riesige ameise
ich finde das so ekelhaft diese teile in
dieser kleinen sind okay aber stell dir
mal vor diversen meter lagen solche
teile dann ist ja sogar marienkäfer ekel
aber was jetzt hier vom wildpark ich
vermisse februar
tschüss